yeah so what would you do if it was  Mother versus child like say if it like  other was pregnant and it was in the  right area but they said  um yeah I think I think the oh the the  purpose should always be to save life  where you can save life right so so if  you can't say if you can't save the  uh would you mean a mother over the  child so like if Cass is saying that  like if there was a situation where the  doctor had assumingly said to someone  that wasn't even the mother because at  this point I'm assuming she doesn't  actually have the ability to communicate  necessarily and  I can't save you and your child what do  I do what would I mean these are  hypothetical situations I mean they not  exist I know there's a there's a group  of doctors in in Ireland that that they  say that actually abortion  um I mean that ectopic pregnancy is is  something different because we're  talking about elective abortion